should we be there bolstering stapleding
together this hollow
a structure that can get blow over as
soon as we're not there if you're not
wanted there which we weren't wanted
there by a large swath of the population
then it's not going to work
let's pivot to a couple more serious
matters
um obviously it's monday what's the date
august 16th when we're recording this
this will go up thursday the 19th
today as of today
we're in the midst of
quite a bit of chaos in in afghanistan
with everything that's going on there
just to kind of recap not that people
are unaware of this after two decades of
of us occupation 2.26 trillion dollars
spent
the u.s pulled its troops out recently
and the result is of course this power
vacuum that's quickly been filled by the
taliban which has moved unbelievably
swiftly to seize control of the entire
country
culminating in
president ashraf ghani fleeing and the
occupation of kabul in the last day or
two
uh taliban just took the presidential
palace i think today not yesterday
yesterday i think we've all seen the
scenes at the airport it's absolutely
horrifying
and
you know there's a lot of uh a lot being
written about the biden administration
dragging its heels despite weeks of of
warnings being incredibly slow to
extract u.s citizens and civilians and
embassy employees there's this delayed
withdrawal that's been causing death and
chaos um
i don't know if you've seen edward
snowden's rants on us on twitter right
now but he's like all over this is he
really yeah because apparently biden
there's a there's an article that i'll
link up
about this but biden had said i think
just a couple weeks ago
that the likelihood that there's going
to be you know the taliban overrunning
everything and owning the whole country
would be highly unlikely and kind of
really dismissing comparisons to the
fall of saigon
as being
out of hand um and of course that's
exactly what we're seeing i mean he said
point blank the taliban is not the north
vietnamese army they're not remotely
comparable in terms of capability
there's going to be no circumstance
where you're going to see people being
lifted off the roof of an embassy of the
united states from afghanistan and
that's exactly what you're seeing right
just hours before i came into the studio
today i saw a video
of one of the c-130s taking off from the
airport and two people i mean the plane
have been a thousand feet above the
ground i saw at least two
thousand people yeah falling to their
death who had been clinging onto the
wheels or something you know yeah there
was there were more people as it was
taking off i think some people slipped
down and decided not to die
and the other two thought they could
stay on there
absolutely that shows you what what
um
people are
feeling about the taliban taking over
everything
um
i i mean i
the taliban might not be as as great as
the north vietnamese army but
possibly the afghanistan military that
we helped build is not as good as the
south vietnamese that's probably really
where where the truth lies there's some
there's some something there the fact
that it just toppled so immediately yeah
you know is unbelievable
and and in such you know stark contrast
to the dollar spent and you know the
soldiers deployed over two decades but
not shocking you know like if you've
read anything i i brought in this book
uh cj chavers wrote the fighters he's a
pulitzer prize winning reporter for the
new york times the best war reporter
possibly of his generation
um
iraq war veteran of the first iraq war
and then spent a lot of time in combat
zones and um it's just a master work of
battlefield non-fiction and if you read
that
um
you can't
but think this is exactly what was going
to happen and uh also that we should be
out so
as opposed to like
for me personally my feeling on this is
is
uh when
9-1-1 happened i was all for
uh
biden i was all for the u.s to to go in
and get the taliban out because
obviously we know taliban gave safe
harbor to bin laden and al-qaeda
and the taliban are
zealots that were murdering gay people
and women in assassination and soccer
stadiums
they were
they blew up the buddha statues they
were
anti-intellectual
anti-human rights um and pro-sharia law
and so you know we we it would be good
to get rid of them as what i thought um
and i still thought that i still i still
think that that was the right move i
didn't
anticipate 20 years of war and
occupation i mean basically trying to
repeat what the soviet union failed to
do um it just doesn't make any sense and
and listen if if what you built with 20
years and 2.26 trillion dollars
topples in a month then maybe it wasn't
the right thing to do and if you look at
it from the perspective of the
guys who are the war fighters the you
know the guys in the us military
as horrible as this pretends to be for
women across afghanistan and and all
sorts of people but basically
intellectuals and women and and lgbtq
and afghanistan as awful as this could
be could become for them
um
you know
uh
is that like should we be
should we be there bolstering stapleding
together this hollow
a structure that can get blow over as
soon as we're not there i mean is that
what we should be doing is that what we
should be asking
our children and brothers and sisters to
die for i mean it's it's an open
question if you read this book you will
think no
um because you know if you're not
wanted there which we weren't wanted
there by a large swath of the population
then it's not going to work and there's
an argument to be made because we were
there the taliban is more tolerated not
less tolerated um now the taliban has to
run the country um and you know there's
gonna be bloodshed it's horrible but at
the same time it's like who should be
doing that work
and um and that's what we're gonna find
out what's gonna happen that's not to
downplay it i'm not downplaying it um
there's a great episode on the daily
from one woman's perspective what she's
going through in this process uh it's
very moving
it's horrible um but that's my thoughts
on it yeah it's amazing how fast
it's happened and i was seeing just
today
the media landscape there has already
shifted like people that own storefronts
are taking down
posters of women and they've removed
music from the airwaves and
the news channels are already you know
reorienting their reporting to ensure
that they're not offending taliban's
sensibilities like
it's unbelievable that it feels almost
overnight and i think when it comes to
judging or addressing the immediate
decisions pulling out not pulling out
how quickly did we get there to evacuate
people what could we have done
differently all of that really seems
futile what we really need to do is
telescope up and and
and evaluate
the
the arrogance of imperialism and its
totality right and this sensibility of
like we're the saviors we're here to
help and we're going to impose military
force and that's going to you know
transform your country into a democratic
utopia i mean how many times
does that experiment have to fail and
how many lives have to be lost and how
much money has to be spent before we get
the message that this is not you know
our problem to solve and it's not
um
you know through our
it it's not our
sensibility to impose on such a foreign
country
to begin with
i don't know i agree with you yeah i
mean i think
the question is how
what happened like afghanistan in the
70s was like uh like the jewel of the
backpacker trail like when the lonely
planet guides were first coming out the
very first guide
you know kabul is like
is like
they they loved kabul and they and they
spent a lot of time in afghanistan and
travelers were there all the time in the
70s you know it wasn't far from india
india and kabul and afghanistan
and the cold war cold war started the
soviets started encroaching and then we
propped up the taliban to
compete with the soviets we didn't prop
up the taliban so we we um we definitely
got weapons and and funds to
uh different
i guess
i don't know if it's tribes but
different different factions of this
kind of because afghanistan is the
progenitor of the taliban well what ends
up happening i think if we charlie
wilson's war is this movie that we both
love mike nichols movie aaron sorkin
wrote the screenplay and it talks about
this whole soviet era and i think what
happens after they routed the soviets
and came out there's that scene at the
end where like charlie wilson is trying
to get more funding to get um social
services back going in afghanistan and
and basically they didn't want to fund
that nobody wanted to fund that then
and so what ended up happening in that
vacuum i think you had forces from iran
and elsewhere coming in with money and
that's when the kind of the the more
sharia law kind of islamist
uh but you know i i'm not 100 sure but
that's my that's what i i think is what
happened and that's when that started to
to take place in the 80s so
um there's an interesting perspective
that that was shared today by
uh dean and aisha cher's a friends of
the pod
neurologists who actually met in
afghanistan they were both there
um during their younger years
that's in contrast to this idea that our
occupation was this paper tiger and it
was all in futility and look how quickly
it it disintegrated and their
perspective is like listen you know yes
that's true but at the same time a lot
was done to empower women support
women's rights and and create you know
two generations or a generation and a
half of women who are in a very
different place as a result of that
influence and now
um
you know us evacuating the the area and
the intrusion of the taliban and the
overtaking
um puts an end to that and not only puts
an end to that kind of
movement but also of course
imperils the very lives of these people
no doubt about it i agree with that
people are going to get executed
it seems that way christiana on ammanpor
on cnn who i love uh was interviewing a
spokesman for the taliban who happened
to be in qatar like another like why is
the spokesman for the taliban in qatar
like what is going on like who is
funding this operation
um
and uh
and that person was saying that we've
we've put out word there there will be
no reprisals we will not x y and z you
know no one's going to get assassinated
nobody to be no reason to be afraid come
to work blah blah blah but there's also
been reports already of
summary executions of soldiers that were
in the afghan military some civil
servants so that report happened she
confronted him with that there's a five
or six minute clip um
that i've got here that was on her
twitter um that we could put up there um
so you know remains to be seen
it doesn't seem like it's gonna be good
um and i i'm
in that in that sense but like what are
you supposed to do like you know
i don't know yeah like what are you what
what are the choices i don't i i would
say this no matter what like what are
the choices i remember when obama was
running for president and he was like
we're gonna get out of the wars and he
didn't get out of afghanistan probably
because he didn't want this thing
happening but uh
but you know at some point you have to
either decide okay we're here for 100
years
or you pull out like eventually
so
yeah i don't know the answer to that
[Music]
you